hey there my name is raine harasaki if
you haven't heard of me i'm an american
breath of the wild player who has spent
over 2 300 hours battling in hyrule
i spent a whole lot of time making
combat videos and pioneering several
breath of the wild techniques
the bowspin for example is one of my
creations so naturally when a game came
along that everyone was touting as a
breath of the wild clone
my interest was piqued and i had to see
what it was like for myself
since its first reveal gentian impact
got both a lot of attention and flack
for its breath of the wild like
appearance and gameplay
making people question its originality
why would i play this game if it's just
the worst version of breath of the wild
they would say after playing this game
for 50 hours i can confirm that yes
it does have similarities to breath of
the wild but that doesn't mean you
shouldn't play it
and there's a lot of interesting things
going on with this game which i'll go
over
to make it easier to digest the
comparison can be split into three main
sections
exploration combat and overall thoughts
this is where i felt gentian impact is
the most similar to breath of the wild
and this is also what was shown most in
trailers leading up to genji
impact's release which made people angry
to the point of destroying ps4s in
protests of this game's development
when it comes to exploration genji
impact really feels like a bit of a
mixed bag
the similarities are obvious to the
point of being blatant the gliding
mechanics are pretty much the same
and both games have the options to climb
or jump up most surfaces
jump off walls attack while falling and
use stamina to sprint and much more
in that respect gentian impact feels
really familiar and it's easy to get
accustomed to the exploration when you
know exactly what you're doing
at times it can feel alarmingly similar
particularly when you reach parts of the
map such as mount hulau and cape oath
which are nearly identical to satori
mountain and cave kales from breath of
the wild
taking inspiration from a game as well
received as breath of the wild is
understandable and honestly more games
should take inspiration from it
but i did begin to wonder how gentian
impacts developers were able to get away
with this level of similarity
genji impact even keeps some of breath
of the wild issues such as automatically
clambering onto objects you didn't mean
to
but to its credit gen chin also
streamlines some things from breath of
the wild gameplay system such as fast
swimming instead of breath of the wild
swim dash
option which limited your ability to
steer link mercifully you can also climb
in the rain in genjen this makes it much
less stressful to traverse when the
weather isn't ideal
even though for the most part people
dislike the rain climbing limitations
difficulties such as these would make
you think more about how to approach
traversal and whether there's other ways
around
in many cases it pushes players into
other mechanics such as camping until
the weather clears
using rivali's gale and other
unconventional methods that can present
alternate ways to get to places
one of the wonders of breath of the wild
is its playground-like world and its use
of multiple tools to manipulate that
world
that's what made it engrossing to be in
while gentian impact doesn't really have
those elements i don't think it's
entirely necessary
as its developers really focus on making
an rpg first
and an open world adventure game second
and that's okay
one thing gen chin does right just like
breath of the wild is the breadcrumb
like exploration
the fact that you can get distracted so
easily when you're going from place to
place makes gangshin impact's world
extremely fun to explore
and makes it rewarding to go out of your
way to scavenge materials on your way to
your next objective
and while the ubisoft tower system is
nothing new or exclusive to breath of
the wild
it's an integral part of exploration
that makes an appearance in gangshin as
well
so is gentian impact's exploration as
good as breath of the wild
exploration not really it's perhaps more
intuitive but not as considered
either way you will definitely get lost
in it and probably enjoy the vast
colorful world
the fact that you get to have that in a
game that's played for free is a huge
plus in my book
my definition of breath of the wild
combat is going to be completely skewed
compared to the average player so i'll
try to approach this from a top down
view in combat in general
i can safely say that this work engine
impact deviates the most from breath of
the wild
and it is immensely fun to play in its
own distinct way while breath of the
wild did heavily use elements in combat
gangshin impact uses them differently
rewarding character swapping to gain
buffs and encouraging element mixing
this is done
by tying each character to a specific
element and when combined with weapons
and artifacts effects it really creates
satisfying depth
this is where the rpg element really
shines and makes elemental play
completely different in gangshin impact
to go a little deeper general combat
overall is fairly different in genji as
well
besides one counter stance character
there's no proper guarding or parry
button against an impact
leaving dash is your only defensive
maneuver and while there are falling
attacks you're unable to do any action
while jumping
making most jump cancels in the game
fairly useless the control scheme in
genchin is also completely different but
it feels good to perfectly dodge an
attack and then blast mixed elements
against your foes
all in all both games are fun in their
own independent way and have rewarding
combat breath of the wild just has a
kind of room for creativity that appeals
to lab monsters like me
the leveling of multiple characters and
progression of artifacts and weapons and
gangshin impacts is a fun system that
gives the game a unique flavor that
channels its gotcha game roots
while acquiring these characters feels
pretty unnatural and completely breaks
the story immersion of the game
the characters are actually all very
unique and all of them can be viable on
a team
except for amber having this character
swapping system
almost makes me want a similar system of
switching characters with zelda and link
in the breath of the wild sequel
but ultimately i think that would feel
unnatural and would break the immersion
of a mainline zelda game
gen impact like i stated before is an
rpg first
in an open world adventure game second
as a person who loves both genres very
much this marriage really does work out
in this case
there are a ton of rpgs out there that
kill the exploration factor with design
decisions such as invisible barriers and
streamlined dungeon crawls that go in a
singular path
and genchin doesn't do that while the
story isn't much to write home about
even when compared to breath of the
wild's rather light story the nice
visual aesthetic
the in-depth combat and the
breadcrumb-like exploration
really creates a sense of immersion and
while yes genji
impacts breath of the wild inspirations
border on outright copying
that shouldn't inspire anger and
objections why wouldn't you want more
games to take inspiration from one of
the greatest games of all time
and remember if you're turned off by
genji's gotcha elements this game is
completely free
with that in mind it makes it hard not
to recommend at least trying this game
out
at the very least it's a good game to
keep you busy until age of calamity and
the breath of the wild sequel shows up
whenever that is and when it does you'll
find me here exclusively on gamespot for
breath of the wild combat content
you can be sure i'll be digging very
deep into that game and if you want to
see more gentian impact content let us
know in the comments below
thanks for watching
[Music]
you